ارفع
ليله السابع من يناير خمسه من رجال شرطه
الامريكيه ينهالون ضربا على رجل اسود يدعى
تايجر نيكونز يبلغ التاسعه والعشرين من
العمر على اثر مخالفه مروريه
مقاطع فيديو نشرتها سلطات الامريكيه
التقطت بكاميرات الشرطه وكاميرا لمراقبه
الشارع اظهرت عناصر الشرطه وهم يعتقلون
الرجل ويحاودون تثبيته باستخدام صاعق ثم
مطاردته وضربه على الرصيف باكثر من اربع
دقائق
المشاهد التي وصفتها السلطات بالمروعه
اظهرت الرجل لان الما بعد ركله ولكمي عده
مرات وهو ينادي والدته
[موسيقى]
بعد ثلاثه ايام من الاعتداء توفي نيكوز
متاثرا بجروحه في مستشفى مدينه فاس واوديع
الشرطيون الخمسه السجن بتهمه القتل
[موسيقى]
قضيه اثار الضجه كبيره في مدن امريكيه عده
متظاهرون خرجوا الى الشوارع غاضبين
مطالبين بوقف عنف رجال الشرطه ومستذكرين
حوادث سابقه كقضيه جورج فلويد والصحي كنان
اندرسون بالكهرباء قبل اسابيع من قبل
الشرطه